[Applause]
hi
[Applause]
i see so many faces that i know and love
hi guys
[Applause]
204 204 you are first
hi
my name is silke i work for proven
television germany
congratulations thank you we're so
thrilled for you
where will you put your oscar in your
home
because your speech was so moving what
did you think about will smith's speech
uh where will i put my oscar in my home
i have no idea
uh
i don't know i feel really i still can't
understand that i'm holding it on this
is the first time i've held an oscar i'm
fred's with eddie redmayne and i've been
to his house
in london and i was everyone was like oh
look his oscar and they all picked it up
and i was like i can't pick it up like i
felt superstitious so this is the very
first time i've even held it so i have
had no thought of where it's going to go
but i will respect it for sure wherever
it is thank you
214.
um what does this win mean to you
uh it's very meaningful to me it was ten
years ago that i got the rights to tell
this story and
i think that was the first year i was
nominated for an oscar
and it was the first year i you know i
had seven films come out in 2011 and so
to be at the awards ceremony in 2012 uh
was the beginning of my career
and to be here 10 years later with the
film that i brought the rights to
that i kind of
willed into existence
is incredibly meaningful
also it's very special
to be part of a film
that
that means something to me in that it
writes a misjustice you know it
re-examines a life it's so important to
give each other our flowers when we're
still alive and i feel like we miss that
opportunity with tammy faye
so it's very special to me i was texting
with her children during the ceremony i
kept texting them
it's a beautiful beautiful moment and
it means so much to me in terms of my
profession but also in terms of my life
and
what i'm putting out into the world
[Music]
you